[Musique]
merci Mahdia consacrer un petit peu tout
le temps aujourd'hui Merci à VOUS là
nous les Vilaine et les pas anodins
qu'on a choisi ce lieu-là pourquoi tu es
important d'être à vilaine c'est là où
tout a été créé c'est le premier
répétition nous l'a fait premier conseil
de madagas
donc pour moi il est très important cet
endroit là et comment l'aimer justement
Macca nous le groupe ont été invité en
tant pétitionniste pour faire un projet
pour le festival opus Pocus donc voilà
attraper un peu des musiciens qui vient
un peu de partout et le style que nous
fait c'est le Mariama effectivement
Maloy de musique qui vient de l'Afrique
de l'Ouest
malibukina Faso Côte d'Ivoire et Madame
[Musique]
parce que l'estime que le maloya on
lui-même il a sauve-moi la vie parce que
vraiment l'école mais tu es vraiment au
fond de la classe heureusement que
maladi la musique et mal accroche
j'aimerais dire ça et pour finalement tu
es une évidence de faire de la musique
oui parce que peut-être une évidence
parce que pour moi
il fait tout naturel
[Musique]
important de raconter dans vos musiques
dans vos chansons
c'est arrivé
à bout de cette maladie voulu toujours
faire
il y a
[Musique]
dans le chemin mandingue c'est toujours
à l'école même moins donc mon chemin
c'était voilà allez voir Monsieur le
Principal et comme il te connait que
vous mettez des familles de maloya et
moment donné
de Farafina voilà c'était un groupe bien
kinabé et c'est là que m'a la découvre
le bal à fond et le Cameroun donc
Marrakech
[Musique]
et comment voilà la suite et la suite
bien
il va falloir du boulot
merci beaucoup Mahdia
[Musique]